mayor Pete finally putting his big boy
pants on and visiting East Palestine but
where's President Biden instead of going
to Ohio President Biden is heading home
to Delaware to relax after his big
Ukraine trip residents are scared about
toxic chemicals but neither Biden nor
Camelot think it's important enough to
show up the White House grilled on Joe's
snub but it was all excuses
is the president for red and blue states
he of course wants to provide that
support does he not want to do it
directly and
percent but I think but I think offering
the assistance offering the help is
doing it directly when you're when
you're seeing the federal government on
the ground providing the assistance that
is needed that is doing it directly
and if that isn't bad enough Pete's
people are somehow making him the victim
Politico reports Buddha judge worlds
frustrated at GOP attacks over the train
wreck with one senior Democrat saying
quote Pete butterjudge has taken a lot
of bullets for the president on this
well Pizza big guy isn't he Jesse Hill
really really take it on well this whole
Transportation gig was supposed to be
his on-ramp to the presidency the
on-ramp has derailed and now he's
whining about it and doesn't look good
doesn't look good in the costume he put
on last night Biden's not not going to
go judge it's too late at this point for
Joe to go this is Trump country he'd
rather just have Pete take the heat for
it he talks a big game about empathy and
the environment and getting back the
white working class in the Rust Belt but
that's all talk you'll never see the
president over there he's going to come
back from Europe he's going to hope this
thing blows over and that's it and
that's sad because the country wants
people there Pete even said it last
night he said there should be everybody
here not just may Trump spin Rudy's been
everybody that cares about the
environment of the country should be
there right now this is kind of captured
the country's Soul our attention and the
people that matter are ignoring it no
Jesse that's a great Point like also
where's Al Gore where's John Kerry
where's the Leo DiCaprio they have no
problem hopping on these private jets to
go talk about environmental issues
somewhere but suddenly they don't want
to get on the private jets to go deal
with an action actual environmental
disaster to bring attention to it and
also like maybe bring some water I don't
believe that the water is safe to drink
and the stunt of drinking like one glass
that's not what's going to get you it's
over time and it reminds me of you know
Flint Michigan about an hour from where
I grew up the water they were saying
it's fine to drink it's fine drink
people are saying I'm sick I'm sick like
people are saying in East in East
Palestine and it took 18 months after
estimated 9 000 babies had ingested lead
water to say okay no it's not
um should be sending pallets Fiji
Harold your turn I want you to take a
listen to uh Democrat congressman John
Garamendi and his take on all of this
the help in East Palestine must come to
Norfolk Southern this is not a taxpayer
problem this is a railroad company
problem they created the problem and
they must be fully down to the very last
penny responsible
okay so this isn't our problem but
Ukraine is explain this for me
so a couple things I think that the
congressman is is largely right from the
standpoint when when there's corporate
malfeasance or Corporate Challenge like
this in corporations in this space
argued for greater leeway and
flexibility and how they were able to
manage their operations but out the
finger pointing has never really been
much strength I think as you we think
right now you if I were anywhere else in
the country where you have these uh
chemicals being transported by by rail I
would want to know because you can look
out your your window you're going to get
your church window your work window your
home window or where you how you travel
to those places
could we have a problem here if our
Congress I think I give Jim Jordan a lot
of credit for going down to the border
with the Judiciary Committee I think
it's important that's those are the kind
of hearings I want to see Congress
holding I'd hold a hearing in East
Palestine drink the water hopefully you
don't get sick they all say it's safe
and I would call the railway operators
from all of the other companies and say
look they're going to do the NTSB is
going to investigate this and I don't
want to get in the way of that but where
do you guys transport chemicals across
the country that you have these kinds of
challenges or potential challenges you
could have and where do you give
subjectivity in terms of control over
when you will stop those trains to
conductors we should change those rules
if I'm the president I hope he goes I
hope you're wrong I hope he goes I would
issue an executive order saying anytime
you have these kind of temperature
increases not not an expert but I think
from 75 degrees to 236 degrees and 40
miles that's a lot so if it I don't know
if the number should be 200 175 150
that's where you have to have experts so
odd whole hearings that ensure we don't
have something like this happen again
and then we can allocate the blame who
whether it's Norfolk Southern their
insurance company whomever it may be
they should all they should all be held
accountable not set in the beginning
Buddha Jets should have been there early
President Biden should have been there
early uh and I don't disagree with you
those environmental activists uh who who
talk a big game there so some of them
should have gone also but we should be
thinking about how we prevent this from
happening over the next several months
before we think about preventing it
let's try to do something in for the
people who've been involved in it right
now wait a minute Katie the issue right
now is that the president is throwing
Buddha judge under the bus okay and but
the truth is that it that FEMA first
refused to even offer assistance when
the president offered a half a billion
on President's Day and today I hear
there was another two billion more that
we're giving Ukraine well look this
story in East Palestine the situation
has everything that Joe Biden claims he
cares about the environment trains
empathy regulation and yet he didn't
show up and now to Jesse's point it's
way too late for him to go and it would
highlight his lead from behind strategy
when it comes to this crisis
domestically at home in a place that he
claims to care about and it totally
blows away his brand of being a hard
charging Blue Collar stand with the
worker kind of guy when he refuses to
show up there but he'll go show up in
Europe or other places where it's more
convenient for him and his narrative and
political prospects and where he's
pulling better and on Ukraine that is
one of them when it comes to Pete
butterjudge the White House is throwing
him under the bus kind of just by
default because Joe Biden has handled
this poorly but yesterday the White
House Press Secretary was defending him
from from the the lecture in in the
briefing room I'm curious how many times
this guy gets to screw up before they
really decide to actually get rid of him
and start over it turns out the
transportation secretary actually has
responsibilities and Pete butterjudge
wasn't up for the job given his lack of
experience even though he was the mayor
who failed to fill potholes I mean where
was he during the the cargo ship crisis
where all the cargo ships were sitting
out to sea where was he when the rail
strike was about to happen he was gone
for that there's a number of things he's
been MIA for this is another one and the
rule is when you start making the
president look bad that's when it's time
to go and he's done that a lot of
different times so you know they say
that they have confidence in him but
we'll see how long that lasts hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else